today I'm going to share with you a
secret
it's uh
secret from when I first went to huama
and
over the years strange things have
happened to me
and a lot of people won't be interested
if you're being interested in the
meditation visualization films but
I'm making here
in the double joke
and perhaps a minority of people out
there would like to
develop their intuition gut feeling
Spiritual Awakening
we can trance vision
we can put all these games to it
but
whether I have a vivid imagination or
not whether you do
listening to me
they will be all decided
for each person to decide if they are
interested in following this
thing or not throughout their life
whether it be in Aikido what other paths
I call it the house the
the small wooden structure
on the Showman
and the showman means
show men means at the front and it's the
head of the room or so it's the head
of the dojo
it's the front
and the head
of the Dover so it's the Showman
so when the Striking in aikida and we
say show manucci ikio for argument's
sake it means you're striking to the
front of their head
I'm sure many of you know this already
I can't remember the cost of the house
but you can get them I think it's
starting around about 300 pounds
I bought the whole set and you can
choose what size bars is what size
dishes pots
but
an average set nowadays
plus post which I would imagine
could be all the things that properly
that you could say in white
and the house
the desk that saves off evil spirits and
on the top shelf the small try
with the
stand
that they put food on in my case
black belt certificates or other things
that I'm presenting
they could normally get
the one I have
with those pallets for between 300 and
500 pounds
so it's not a small investment is it
so anybody who is serious about
not the religious size side but just
respecting the uncensity
respected his own heart and for his art
he needed to follow a religion and it
was his way of connecting with Heaven
and Earth
and asking look how my the spirits the
Gods
to come and help him in his training and
in his life
a lot of religions won't allow this so
they wouldn't have this Shinto
kamidana is called the house
and and coming down
comprises with all the items
and the name is the ginger
so
it would basically be if you're looking
up on the Internet or you want to to
research it more the Japanese wooden
home size
Ginger set
it's a sharing a Shinto Shrine God news
Sorry God
can use it so
and I think mine would have been a small
little medium but I know there's very
small ones but this is for those of you
who are interested
I'd now like to go on to
parting with the secret
when I went to well I didn't have
anything like this I just had a
showerman with a cloth on it and a few
items that I chose
and this can be seen in some of my
early dojos where all I had was a
picture of those scents
and a lot of places around the world
that's all I have
because perhaps they train in a Sports
Hall and they just bring the picture
along put it on waste it against the
wall or something and they bow to her
sensing
if to me you know fortunate enough to be
able to have your own personal dojo
then it's a sacred place for you and
when I said this earlier it doesn't mean
you have to follow religion for it to be
a sacred place it can be a place like
nowadays we call things man caves so we
could call this my man cave
my first trip to Obama I was looking
forward to it I'd seen a lot of pictures
I'd heard a lot about it
I arrived I trained
in the dojo
viewed those sentences very small one
where he lived with his wife
his modern Tamil it
it wore you'd call the European toilet
and the almost a size too small to get
into
his Library
small kitchen that's not used now only
for resting the
ugachu in the afternoons when it's hot
we can sleep in the
and across the road there's not across
the road across the yard there's a sort
of a very basic boring unit being built
where
the dash we all needs
and it can accommodate quite a few
I don't know I say quiet and I'm going
to guess
20 people perhaps more
at the end of it
there's a sliding
door that takes you into where you can
have a shower very very basic
um
and the washing machine
they're only allowed to use the washing
machine at certain times
and the shower is not what you would
class
of much use apart from it will give you
water and you can wash yourself
the yard is very nice to walk around
if you go up at 5 00 am in the morning
and the air is still
and you can just have your own thoughts
so to me
when no one's around
okay why am I in the morning and very
late after 10 o'clock in the evenings
if you ever go there that is the time to
find yourself just have your thoughts
just look around
I'm going to be Road here and say
there's nothing special
apart from the glory and the excitement
of you actually being into those
sentences grounds
and where he spent many years developing
the art of Ikea
that's not the secret that I want to
tell you about and I'm going to make
this particular story in two parts
but I just want you to get the feeling
of the surroundings
the dojo is a connection part of Jose's
house
the dojo in itself in size I would say
is at least twice the size of our senses
living accommodation
it's very strange how you seem to put
more
importance on the space to train
students and what he required to live in
the dojo that I'm standing in now is my
smallest
at the end
it's
twice as big as his living accommodation
of his actual
what I would consider his living room
where he would sleep and and socialize
when you come out of the
dojo
land and you walk towards
you have to go out to the to a road as
time Academy Road
and I don't know why but
opposite the entrance to the dojo
or the the road that goes into the dojo
area
opposite this time that road you walk
across the line
and her since he built his Ginger
opposite
he built some very strange structures
and they're enclosed behind a wooden
fence and there are pictures out there
so you can see them
and I wonder what went through his mind
when he built these strange wooden
structures
are they works of art I have no idea to
me
I wasn't impressed
but I still wondered why he built what
he did while he placed them where he did
and I'm sure the Japanese were no far
more than I do and perhaps one day
unrefined the answers to this
the next
section of the film is going to be
my secret
what I gained from it
and what I've held to this day and well
to the end of my days
something very profound
[Music]
um
I hope you will find interesting
thank you for your time so far
in this series
of meditation visualization
and travels work
for those wishing to find
a deeper understanding of self
and the connection between this world
and the spirit world
and you will only find this
if you really
either stand or cross it
like myself not believing in any forms
of there being an afterlife
no push into the hair about the
stupidity of spirits go
or anything of such nature
if I can't say it then I didn't believe
in it
but after having profound changes
throughout my life
I'm now cannot deny
what has been put in front of me
and I will tell you more in the next
social
thank you